another Swift is taking over Hollywood
plus late-night TV was kind of lit last
night pregnant cardi B co-hosted with
Fallon Andy Cohen asked milo ventimiglia
to name three Mandy Moore songs and Seth
Meyers revealed he had his baby on the
floor of his apartment building yeah you
guys heard that last one right Seth
Meyers has the craziest story about the
birth of his second child and we have
more on that in just a few but first you
know Taylor Swift might be one of the
biggest artists in music and now her
younger brother Austin is doing his
thing in movies Austin has worked with
Pierce Brosnan and Ben Affleck and is
now ready to step into the spotlight
with a leading role in the film cover
versions and et's Kell tonight was with
him exclusively at his big screen
premiere but now you're the leading man
so what did you learn from working with
those guys that you took into this role
I think the biggest thing you learn is
just from seeing them work is how good
they actually are and great they
actually are and you learn to aspire
higher than you thought you had to yeah
it's like the calls aspiring actors like
you aspire to be that good and that
capable and so tried to bring a little
bit of that to this one leading man
you're thrust in the Hollywood light did
you get advice from Taylor to handle
this world a lot of advice in all
aspects but um I think the best advice I
get from Taylor is that she says I can
do things that I can actually that you
know and in the sense that you know a
lot of times I'm more reserved and
cautious and she's like you can do it
you can handle it
and that's always it's always nice to
have that in the background fearless if
you would say pun intended
well how fitting that today is actually
national sibling day but I want to know
who would you rather have dinner with
Taylor and Austin Swift or cardi B and
her sister Hennessey I'm just saying it
would be a blast to hang out with cardi
as Jimmy Fallon found out last night
when the rapper joined him as guest
co-host on The Tonight Show it is so
great to have you I'm so excited to see
you that I might go into labor
so I'm making history tonight where I'm
the first late-night co-host days and a
white guy was so bad well speaking of
late night white guys Andy Cohen is
doing a week of watch what happens live
in LA and last night welcome guest Milo
Ventimiglia and Ricky Martin and I was
in the audience and got the best photo
of all time like tell me that does not
deserve to go up in the Louvre or Time
Magazine's here in review I'm just
saying even Milo's giving it a 10 all
right Andy put the to smoke shows in the
hot seat though and straight up a smile
Oh to name three songs from his this is
us co-star Mandy Moore Milo named 3
Mandy Moore song
[Applause]
I think her album was called candy
and wasn't there a song called crush yes
that's - I know she was she was only
like 15 when she was driving the bug oh
man I don't know the rest I really don't
I played that back you guys cuz you
could see me at the edge of the frame at
the very beginning that clip all right
before his part Ricky was asked about
that awkward Barbara Walters interview
you know the one you know where she
pressed him about his sexuality well
here's what he really thought of that
whole thing I felt like she was knocking
like punch after punch after punch he
was really uncomfortable to be honest
but then again I look at it like why did
I say yes back then we're just saying
yes yes I'm gay okay you know I gotta
say I was actually not expecting that
answer from him but it makes sense y'all
Ricky's no longer livin la vida loca
he is settled down married and a father
of two and I'm not gonna lie I'm hoping
they adopt me
look how perfect that family is right
but moving on to this wild story from
Seth Meyers he revealed on late night he
and his wife welcomed their son Axl
straw except the baby was coming so fast
that Seth called an uber and they didn't
make it this after their first son was
almost born in an uber take a look
my wife just says I kick in the car I'm
gonna have the baby right now the baby
is coming and I
I just tried trying to calm her down I'm
like look this is it again I know
because I've been through exactly one
birth and like this happens all the time
you're feeling it's not trust me I know
Anna and but even our doula neither was
saying like look it's this is you're
gonna be fine and she's like my wife is
saying the baby is coming the baby is
the baby is out at which point a newly
looked and then looked at me and said
the baby is out
and I looked at my wife and the only way
I can describe how my wife looked was
she looked like someone who was hiding a
baby in a pair of sweat pants so it was
totally sneak a baby on a plane don't
worry guys we checked with uber and the
Myers got a refund that's right they
told us in a statement quote we were so
happy for set in a Lexie on the birth of
their second child we refunded the trip
and are sending them our best wishes but
here's hoping their ratings still intact
alright that was crazy you know I've
been talking a lot about babies this
week so far but thanks for watching
anyways guys be sure to head over to ET
online.com slash daily denne for all
these stories and my Coachella preview
we'll be live on Thursday at 12 p.m.
Pacific with everything you need to know
about Beyonce and the music festival
just make sure you're subscribed to it
okay bye